what a tortilla chip looks and tastes
like what's an amazing thing that came
out of nowhere you just went into may i
magic yes
ted oh wait
yeah
that that's a tv you really can't eat
right before you start talking may i
have one for ted yes you may oh come on
i need to i need to do it okay after
you're done
that's true when chris comes up that
means it's a free game for chips
all right a lot of people eating right
now so we'll give you the forecast
so tempting we'll wait till after i
promise because i'll get like ten of
those all right live look outside right
now uh good looking day today a little
chilly skies have cleared okay a lot of
you were excited about that but the
temperatures stayed on the chilly side
to keep those chips away from me right
now i'm telling you it's tempting
temperatures for the day today were
actually cold this morning 30 degrees i
knew i knew i knew you're going to do
that
so tempting summerlin 30 degrees this
morning centennial hills 30 for use
henderson at 30 as well spanish trails
at 31 these were all below freezing 32
degrees at the freezing mark this is how
cold it was i promise you i'd show you
the 20s look at these areas they hit the
20s henderson airport mountains edge
nellis 28 southern highlands 29 remember
the edges of town tend to get colder
because you're away from the center of
town that has all the concrete all right
and we're going to see that again
tomorrow morning 47 at sky canyon
centennial st for you spring valley 45
48 north las vegas 50 sunrise manor 50
also for whitney ranch 45 mountains edge
49 southern high or i should say in
henderson 45 right now for 45 bullet
city 55 laflin so if you're going out
tonight jacket for sure needed because
it's obviously going to get colder and
colder as we get through tonight we're
only in the mid 40s right now radar
network clear skies after the snow
showers we had in some neighborhoods
yesterday even the four corners were
clearing out from the showers and snow
we had yesterday wind however will pick
up a little for tomorrow for your friday
i like the sound of that friday right
winds will pick up but nothing too
breezy at all saturday however we will
see some of these neighborhoods here see
a little bit more wind but again not
strong enough for any wind advisories to
be issued however those of you downriven
in lafayette bullhead city lower
colorado river valley yes you will have
gusty winds over the weekend
unfortunately you've been seeing that
lately your weekend looks good 57
degrees friday 58 on saturday sunday 61.
so unfortunately this is still below
average we should be 65 degrees but at
least it's warmer than those 40s we had
yesterday for daytime highs 34 overnight
cold again your high tomorrow 57 degrees
unseasonably cool because we should be
at 65 degrees neighborhood by neighbor
temperatures i think we're going to
reach 60 in the valley a lot of you like
spring valley 56 degrees mountains edge
56
same for north las vegas in those
neighborhoods there near ann and decatur
57 for green valley highs tomorrow going
to be 54 degrees for from that's it your
8 day forecast shows plenty of sunshine
that warming trend begins tomorrow
eventually back to the 70s nearing 80 on
wednesday and then we'll knock those
temperatures back down the 60s as we
head into nascar weekend with breezy
where did chips go brian finished them
this is not okay yeah it's got to be
about you know literally a full bowl
yeah just like a vacuum that's the story
of my life
seriously news you lose today yeah great
speaking of hockey yeah speaking of
hockey here we go
we're going to make that left again
hey the golden knights are getting ready
for what